you want to share with enzo no why
[Music]
hello everyone good morning it's not the
morning
but that's usually what i say it is
afternoon time and can you guys hear
that
we have visitors let's go see who's here
who's this hi hi
leah hi enzo hi isaac hi christina
hi kitty cats no kitty cats no kitty
cats
let's see hi maya you're
freaking out lady she absolutely hates
it when there's visitors
she has just never been accustomed to
visitors poor
maya but hi
oh my gosh is he sliding down careful
leah don't hit your brother
he's such a boy how cute
oh you having fun leah thank you for
cleaning my floors
they were very dirty before you got here
you're welcome now you got a sweet trail
right there
man i missed you guys it's been how long
since we've seen you at home
oh my goodness too many too many you
haven't seen and christina
and enzo and leia in like months it's
been like i think
three months november december january
february
yeah three months so it's been so long
and then now enzo has teeth
he's walking what's happening and then
look at leah your hair got so long girl
and then now isaac is a teenager
your voice is so deep we thought it was
casey that opened the door
yeah sometimes i see him walking around
on my case oh snaps it's isaac
they do like yeah like the same thing
almost oh hey hi guys what are you guys
up to
we are making some smoked honey tacos
and some autobahn can i say it right
yeah yeah
very good i've been craving it we went
to this place called tacos
in san diego yeah that's the spot make
like smoked
meats so they're like originally from
tijuana stuff like that it was our first
time having it
it's the best then i've been craving it
yeah casey used to just drive down to
san diego just for these times or else
yeah oh man one year was like my
birthday and then i
i like literally i'm like hey bart no
you guys want to talk about porto and
they're like
that's what you want casey yeah i
remember because like two hours
that was the birthday that same year i
had a
cinco de mayo i had a cinco de mayo
party at my house
and i invited casey and he was like oh
i'm actually going to go to san diego
to go eat some tacos are you ever dating
yet no no
this is before you wanted to get to know
me you
invited me over for a second yeah i was
like wow
no food's better than you wow
so he's trying to get him worse
you know you're married to this right i
am yes
way down the list wifey is way up now
thank you
yeah you have your priorities in order
now and i appreciate that
i appreciate that anyone's asking for a
banana can i steal this banana
no leah no i'm just kidding i love you
i'm sorry if i scared you her little
eyes when i said no she was like
i let you you read her like i'm just
kidding i'll just go give
[Music]
oh cutie
no well kinda sorta not really so i
ended up hitting him up to go to some
show actually i guess i did because i i
hit him up first
but it wasn't like with romantic
intentions it was more for like
friendship
intentions and then he took it as
romantic intentions
but it was more friendship yeah so yeah
i was just trying to like
i was just trying to be friends like hey
dude i'm having a party i'm inviting all
these other people you want to come too
he's like nah it's my birthday tomorrow
so i'm like okay sorry you're really
innocent
platonic that was my intention but not
this guy this guy
what wanted more look how sexy this guy
looks with his purse
[Music]
hey
yeah actually yeah he's he's kind of
lost a lot of his curls now it's like he
just got it
way straight and then only at the very
tips is it like still curly
you should get it permed again huh you
should you should
oh yeah i wonder what that would look
like that would look pretty good perfect
he's like wait you're serious this is
getting pretty serious right now
you wouldn't be down it i'll do it for
you guys yeah for us no do for you
you wouldn't be down to experiment i
mean it only lasts like
it only lasted like a month for him it's
supposed to last like three years so
straight
and it just like fought against the perm
so it's like practically not
permanent yeah let's
[Music]
i don't know peer pressure peer pressure
let me think about it let me think about
it
you get our air from the very next day
and show the ball
it's like i couldn't do it guys no
regrets guys no regrets
what about you baby i was about to ask
you what about you let me see come here
i only do that isaac does it oh nice
look at this man watch this this is him
he's like
i like my hairstyle
i know are you guys let me see how tall
is he
next to you
i'm not gonna play him basketball dang
isaac
you're going to through crazy crazy
growth spurts arms
[Music]
[Applause]
wait mama's getting distracted okay oh
snap
like barely like almost like half an
inch and christina's
still taller a little bit taller yeah
you're still a little bit taller but i
think isaac's about to beat you like in
a month
or less yeah like five two right now is
he no way
oh she's five two i think it's the hair
yeah right that's true he's not growing
it can't be true
no because i'm 5'4 so he hasn't reached
my height yet not you know what's next
now that you're growing muscle
oh he's been killing it every day yeah
every day
for the past how many days three days
four days a week yeah
25 questions whoa you got absolutely
pretty soon though with those teenage
like body hormone thing whatever you
know how like immediately they get
yolked out
yeah yeah i see it happening pretty soon
we should come over to your place
because you have a whole like
rack and stuff yeah and i don't even
work out oh then that might be
motivation
for you to work out if isaac's coming
over yeah i'm down we're gonna work out
with joe
joe works out almost every day oh tight
yeah would you be down
why are you standing on this are you
trying to be taller now
you can't wait and i'll be looking at
you like this like hi
isaac give mama a hug
you know like my son is so much taller
than me
so what are you doing right now i just
added some
onions and bell peppers to the bacon but
what are you making though next step
will be
the beans oh you're making beans
this is a recipe i learned during my
college days and it's
served me well but i've also tweaked it
along the years so it's now
my recipe oh is it my cuban beans recipe
yeah nice i know they actually come out
really good one of my favorite things
that it makes
and it's the one pot meal one pot meals
being the key to serving a group of
people or
your family being able to like kind of
meal prep it and it just kind of stays
in the fridge for a week and
just kind of circling if you're hungry
true nice and easy nice
that looks good thank you very much what
about you
i don't know i just saw this in here
that we brought over and we don't use
them they're gonna go
bad oh no i'm like we gotta make some
you wanna make some guacamole with them
to keep these ones
whatever you want to do or do you look
like little chunks yeah let's do it i
like chunks but we
do yes no wait what do you mean what do
you mean people do like the salsa block
thing
yeah with chunks right yeah but then
like the chunks it's like you can add it
to your pico
oh i am doing pico next oh no for
whatever leave me out of decisions with
food i don't know i just want to eat it
i just i will eat it but i don't know
about making it or preparing it or what
i would want i have no requests
you guys just use your art artiste
you're living the life
that's the life i want what's the life
no decisions just
feed me and i want to eat some bomb food
i'm so spoiled that's literally my life
every day i love it
thank you honey i love you
what's going on i have you up and down
the stairs
yeah hi oh let's take him to the park
oh yeah yeah yeah you want to go to the
park let's go to the park
yeah we haven't been to the park in like
a year oh my god
oh my goodness he loves it
yeah so inside of our community we have
a little tot lot is what they call it
usually when and christina come over
there's never a chance to go to the top
lot because
it's usually around sunset time which is
about this time still so we're gonna try
to squeeze in
a little play at the top lots
while the sun's still out you ready to
go explore look isaac's on his
hoverboard
let's go to the top lot david can you
close the backyard door please
he just runs around wild yeah oh yeah
like stretched out
what you gotta be careful dude
you really trust the kid you wanna go
play on the playground no i think don't
don't get too comfortable it's scary
it's easier if you put them on your head
in my opinion from experience dang dude
full big brother mode no that's how
babies are carrying plus he's wearing a
diaper
it's like he's wearing a cup because
then when you have them on your hip it's
just one
one armhole and then also he's not
comfortable
i feel it i just feel bad but what he's
wearing a diaper isaac you're being
weird boys
because when you used to carry me it
hurt sometimes really
did you remember that you had the wrong
angle
sorry i didn't know that yeah so i just
feel bad i don't have a set
no i want to wear it oh my gosh you're
so funny
got it good job whoa big girl climbing
one more time you ready wow good job
leah
oh someone wants to follow oh he's like
sister's doing it i could do it boys
good job leah you did it
you did it you wanna you wanna go down
leah i'll catch you i'll catch you
girlfriend
one two three whoa good job
how about enzo come on enzo how are you
gonna go let's see
ready let's go let's go yeah ready
go snap
good job leia you caught your brother
when it's chinese new year time what do
the kids get what are you gonna get leah
what are you gonna get
he's talking to you wait i wanna vlog so
i just told
my vlog but i'll tell your it's chinese
new year time
yeah and then during chinese new year
time kids get something right
what do they get what do they get what
do you get
so excited excited too i'm excited too
she's waiting for something i have a
present for you leia you ready
you ready for your present me and uh me
and uncle casey have a present for you
this is the traditional way you gotta
stand shoulder to shoulder yeah
wait hold on yes like this wait leah
you're leaving oh she wants me to hold
her
she's like i need to have clean hands
for this she already knows
you know the drill girlfriend
hi enzo enzo's ready too all right leia
we have a little something for you
girlfriend
yeah presents more presents
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
what did i mean uh happy new year oh i
think we were saying
like you're not gonna get it then or
something
[Music]
that's me yeah look at what look at what
they gave you
look leah are you gonna go to sleep it
matches your dress
it's pink there's flowers on it what's
inside
what's inside your head wow
what's inside leia say thank you
you're welcome when you're
we want to be um a good girl this year
and we want you to be a good a good
daughter and a good
sister which you already are okay
that's your your
let me see how much i like you dia let
me look in here real quick
we're like yeah that's about right yeah
we went off we're good yeah we're good
and enzo look at them one for you too
buddy
thank you say thank you
thank
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
little brother
[Music]
isaac's gonna be the first kid that
we're ever gonna give it to you
oh really yeah this way you haven't
followed the tradition ever
how long have you been married a while
oh great because traditionally
as a married person you're you're now
supposed to give it to people younger
than you
you know it's funny this was actually
the first year that we did it like it's
the first day that you know we're giving
it to them
and then we gave them to his brother and
his his fiancee so it's like
i don't know we've been waiting for
three years now we owe you guys like
eight years
you do oh do you now
isaac he has headphones on put your
headphones down really quick
yeah so uh uncle and auntie wanna give
you something
good yeah
[Music]
you're welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
a year full of happiness and a lot of
money
and video games and right here thank you
oh cutie i really appreciate it
enjoy it wow dude it looks like
jerky almost like hey now it's bomb
it's got a little char on it already so
it's definitely a smoke yeah let's cook
it on uh
on the stove charred a little bit oh we
got the pro in the house
hi leia she's loving her lacy money
oh don't put it on your face girlfriend
oh but this looks long
all right so i've been mindful of the
fact that we have like
zero kid toys and every time they come
over i'm always like
oh i need to get some more kid toys or
something that i can have around the
house
especially because we want to have more
kids or whatever and so i purchased
this this thing right here
is actually a wooden kids toy
so i'm about to give it to leia and enzo
so they could play with
but i actually created what i figured
what happened
it just spoke to us
[Music]
oh my gosh it works
okay way better than that yes right
oh my god yes okay so another update
with oh look she's telling me smoke
is detected
[Music]
oh that's so cool i bought three of
these nest smoke detectors
like in september i think and so i've
been meaning to install them for many
many months
and then finally we installed them i
think last week oh also i installed
dimmers all by myself look at this
[Applause]
actually taught me what to do before he
left and then i ended up doing them on
my own because i had to order them and
they came after he left look at that
so i installed dimmers down here
i also have dimmers for upstairs in the
bedroom but i haven't finished them all
yet yeah so i installed these smoke
detectors because it's always beeping
like crazy and now it's safer and now
it's
not as annoying there's so many things
that haven't updated you guys in
forever we just kind of took a little
vlogging break we were working around
the house doing a lot of stuff
what's happening don't fall in though
you okay isaac yeah let me get your
drink
[Applause]
oh snaps you gotta be careful leia
i want grandkids leia yeah don't be mind
spreading with kids around isaac good
luck leah
look leia your money that you're hit
under a money
why'd you hide it no i'm gonna steal it
i got a wooden toy that's kind of like a
rainbow and you can play with it and
make your own designs and do whatever
you want
uh-oh yeah let enzo play too yeah
it's my attempt to have one toy sorry no
but it's nice because it is kind of like
decorating yeah
i had it as hell i had it as decor i had
no idea
we started messing with it and then when
your smoke alarm went off i thought it
was the toy that was like making them
it was just perfect timing for
everything but i like how you always
have toys where you can like assemble it
and like get creative through
like the normal toys that are just like
built in yeah
they just have a whole bunch of
batteries this is old school toys do you
want to share with enzo
no why look you can put them in here
leia look right here
whoa she was quick to not share
[Applause]
oh no so cute he copies everything she
does he's so cute
and so a nice absorbent little brother
yeah he absorbs everything he always
tries to do everything that she does but
he tries to do it like 10 times harder
peekaboo
[Music]
it could make like a cat you want to
make like a cat
or a turtle is that a turtle that looks
like a turtle
hey that was fast girl what else do you
want to make
you want to do that's a rainbow they're
not disinfected everything in his mouth
like i don't know i don't know if that's
a good idea and so let's not
make it mold okay it's a hat it's like a
headband
so you need a bigger one i know that i
think this fits better this reminds me
of that cat that like has a
watermelon on top of the head oh yeah
i've seen that
your little cat watermelon head oh my
gosh
look check out the actual smoke by the
lake oh
it's smoky in here yeah so even though i
was the alarm
because of
[Music]
thank you leia you're helping isaac's
upstairs with the towel
by the other two smoke detectors so
there's two but two more up there
and then we have a sprinkler system so
i'm like
oh no there's a sprinkler wait that is a
sprinkler system guys
yeah so the reason why i'm not too
worried about the sprinklers is because
they're supposed to come out whenever it
detects heat
so it's not smoke triggering or
triggered by smoke thank you for
sticking
a good tina i don't want your sprinklers
to go off
he's two teenagers want to come over
here ready go hair ready
look at that we got mexican chaatsu
right here got my
beans i actually forgot about the beans
a little bit
i was supposed to uh cook it on a higher
temp to get rid of this liquid
so smoking barbecue meat there's meat
and then there's the bark on the outside
in between the bark and the meat is a
smoke ring it's like the red part
so judging from what we're looking at
here carnosaur literally has no
bark but it's all smoke ring it's just
all red and so is uh alabama so
we did the job we smoked it so i'm very
very excited to see how these smoke
tacos turn out
great idea thank you it's deceiving
because it's soaked in that's why i'm
like is it ready
or like true you can't tell if it's like
smoke ring or
raw meat next time we gotta get some
thicker pieces yeah
we can manage the cook times better that
way yeah
nice we got the table pretty much set up
leia you're enjoying that chip
thank you uncle casey oh
cute you like your beans
hurry
we're celebrating too early well it
looks good
at least you you nailed the aesthetic
that's this guy right here there we go
the director
good job baby i i hear you
want to find the real influence here
[Music]
you're so cute i keep trying to talk
about ceviche
isaac teenager
oh my favorite thing ever i don't know
how to serve everyone
oh i just slice it yeah and put it on a
plate no you just i don't leave it in
there just slice it oh snaps dude you're
adding ceviche
on your carna salad taco yup whoa let me
know how that tastes because i've never
seen that oh and you also
have crushed chips in there i shouldn't
have added that
that was a bad idea can't make sure to
lean it how is it
really pretty good well you took a bite
without letting everyone see you take
the first bite we never do that
i apologize everybody
let's see it
[Music]
you know what's satisfying to watch is
when two asian guys
watch mexican eat tacos that we made for
them
that's fats like right
[Music]
chinese guys know how to make a good
taco
mexican approved
[Music]
you